I'm in the news once again first it was
because apparently some guy a horrible
man ran a Russian social media account
where he posted clips from one episode
of our show which constitutes a fan I
suppose then we get this other juror in
the E Gene Carroll Story the rape trial
for Trump who apparently watched four
episodes of the show as well and they
said that constitutes him being a fan
and for that he should be disqualified
from the jury
they also called me an extremist a
conspiracy theorist and all the other
nonsense but I do think it's fascinating
that they would go that far you've
watched a show a couple times kick him
off the jury that's how you know they're
an occult because I I don't see
conservatives or the right or decided
liberals doing anything like that or any
sane jury how often do you hear of of a
jury any side plaintiff defendant
whatever being like this guy watched
four episodes of Rachel Maddow they
should be removed from the trial that's
how insane these people are